il n buzzati josée legault michel surgit
bonsoir pourquoi alors noël on a on
parle beaucoup de noël de coire en l'air
notre noël je vous fais entendre les
deux premiers ministres monsieur legault
monsieur trudeau c'est sur l'aspect ce
que on lui demandait la question est ce
qu il l ait imposé aux provinces certain
nombre de mesures pour limiter la
propagation pendant les faits il
monsieur legault qui parle du casse tête
entre autres pour les parents je pense
que cette idée d'évoquer la loi sur les
urgences ou 1 1
une une des directives agressive du
fédéral
on n'est pas rendu là et j'espère qu'on
se rendra pas là je pense pas qu'on va
se rendre parce que ce que je vois des
provinces et qu' ils sont en train
d'agir ils sont en train de créer plus
de restrictions pour qu'on puisse
justement à ralentir la progression de
la cave et 19
pendant ces semaines là si jamais on
étend les vacances il n'y aurait pas de
prestation de services donné pendant ces
semaines la la la question qu'on se pose
bon quand on parle d'avant noël c'est de
voir s'il y avait eu pilos paul qu une
augmentation importante qu'il y aurait
une urgence de poser des gestes
s'assemblent poète le corps là c'est
davantage en fonction d'eux peut-être
mettra en place une espèce de 41 une
quarantaine d' utile pour les enfants
après est-ce passer tout seul chelsea
roger alors il ne l'a pas dit monsieur
legault me l'a quasiment a dit on va
ajouter une ou même deux semaines du
congé de noël
il va y avoir on sait pas quel nom doit
être permis mais ça va être plus que
n'ont permis dans bien des familles des
prétendants elle dépend toujours de la
cetera il là il ya des occasions de
propagation est ce qu'on veut pas c'est
que les enfants ne ramène à l'école à
tresses pixi soit un facteur de
contamination alors ce qu'il faut faire
c'est attendre deux semaines mais ils
vont ils vont attendre deux semaines
après le 1er janvier puis on repartira
les écoles autour de la mi janvier ccc
ça tombe sous le sens ça vaut peut-être
causé des problèmes à des parents c'est
un fait mais c'est quand même quelque
chose qui tombe sous le sens et qui est
une mesure de santé publique
ouais josée legault c'est pas mal écrit
dans le ciel oui est bon on verra à
l'usure comme dirait l'autre mais ce qui
est quand même inquiétant dans tout ça
malgré tout désolé d'être toujours
l'équipe du panel mais c'est que cette
quarantaine
c'est une quarantaine virtuels vont il
ya personne qui va rentrer dans les
maisons des gens pour aller vérifier si
les gens sortent ou pas il va y avoir
quand même plein de commerces qui vont
être ouverts il ya des services
essentiels et services de santé continue
et dans les réunions familiales si on
ajoute la possibilité d'avoir deux
ménages trois ménages
il va y avoir des personnages
il va y avoir des personnes aussi à la
santé plus fragile donc c'est pas juste
une question pour les enfants
l'inquiétude est pas juste pour les
enfants ce qu'ils vont ramener ça à
l'école ou pas mais est ce qu'il ya des
personnes fragiles qui pendant ces
rassemblements aller au privé dans des
lieux clos où s'échangent et tuteurs de
choses qui pourraient être infectées par
l'aco vide et donc qui serait un risque
beaucoup plus important pour leur santé
vous savez c'est ça fait plusieurs
semaines qu'il ya cette espèce
d'obsession pour noël mais est ce que
c'est vraiment prudent de s'en aller
vers ça comme si c'était une récompense
ou une pause on pensait qu'un petit
tampon un vain mot itampon après ça va
tout régler
je sais pas je me pose la question oui
d'accord je vais revenir avec sa après
je sais pas ce que même s'il disait il y
en a pas la question est ce que c'est
réaliste de penser que les gens me
minimalement se réunir parce que la lna
on attendait ces messieurs surtout
qu'ils aient atteint poserait pas des
règles mur à mur
non puisque dans tous les autres
domaines d'ailleurs ça fait mon dieu ça
fait huit mois qu'on demande à monsieur
trudeau s'ils vont imposer ouest reso
d'urgence dans différents scénarios et
la réponse est toujours la même sinon
une raison ceci pose simplement parce
qu'ottawa veut pas avoir l'air du
méchant mais c'est parce que c'est pas
nécessairement logique stack chaque
région
od réalité épidémiologique différentes
commandes des approches différentes
alors ça serait pas nécessairement
logique pour répondre à une des
préoccupations que l'on entend beaucoup
par rapport à ceux deux semaines de
congé les gens disent mais que feront
les parents qui devront s'occuper de
leurs enfants
je serai juste vous signaler quand même
que bon la pcu et les choses du passé
montrent de nouveau programme qui
ressemble beaucoup le notamment la
prestation de relance économique pour
les prochains dans la pcr pea je
m'excuserais de devoir fermer leur
gueule
je m'appelle comme ça donc cette
prestation aussi 2 500 dollars la minute
par ce même risque vous lis jamais que
les gens devaient rester à la maison
sur ordre de la santé publique et bien
la prestation pourrait être offerte donc
les parents pourraient peut-être rester
à la maison avec leurs enfants pendant
ces deux semaines l'eau et à être
dédommagées oui deux semaines de plus
évidemment on aura compris
au total ça ferait 4 semaines loin déjà
près des dommages mais ça reste un
casse-tête comment vous avez jugé la
réaction des syndicats d'enseignants qui
ont dit à michel seydoux en tout cas pas
question encore un syndic en particulier
pas question qu'on reprenne ce temps là
l'été prochain puis c'est non c'est non
on notera patrice que c'est un discours
de leurs segments sont en négociation
comme pas mal tout le secteur public et
que c'est une recette façon de montrer
qu'on va être dur à négociations que de
dire point de compromis jamais c'est
dommage qu'on fonctionne comme ça un peu
mais c'est un peu de rituels des
négociations on verra rendu à la fin de
l'année ce qui se passera mais je dire
si on signe un contrat plus que tout va
bien
ça risque d'être un autre temps oui oui
c'est saint clair s'il le ciel gens qui
sont là dessus michel est tout à fait
raison sur le contexte comme message à
la population c'est pas non c'est pas
chouette et c'est pas solidaire et s'est
montré une inflexibilité quel que soit
le motif là que quelques pas de son seul
désir ont pleinement dans la population
font des sacrifices vont continuer à en
faire je sais que les enseignants
travaillent très fort et sont épuisés
il ya plein de monde y puiser dans les
sociétés occidentales en ce moment là
donc plus un peu de flexibilité au delà
des négociations ce serait bien bon
alors comme vous j'ai réalisé
ajouté qu'il aurait quand même moyen de
prolonger l'année avant noël jusqu'au 23
décembre dernier quelques jours là est
par ailleurs me semble-t-il qu'on a
affaire à une année scolaire qui est
déjà hors norme
venez pas me faire accroire que les
apprentissages seront les mêmes que dans
une amie régulière alors peut-être que
aussi on pourrait avoir un peu plus de
flexibilité sur le nombre de jours que
doit comporter cette année scolaire
parce que autres le syndicat
moi je suis certaine qu'il ya bien des
parents qui ne verrait pas d'un bon oeil
qu'on prolonge l'année scolaire jusqu'à
la mi juillet tout le monde sera facile
il faudrait alors lâché du lest l'oprag
éthiquement là dessus oui est-ce que je
vais changer qu'on peut utiliser aussi
ok flexibilité caisse et où je jouais
scrutin car m joseba et rapide marois
juge est ce que est ce que pour des
raisons familiales et par tous est ce qu
on pourrait aussi parler des poids des
personnes déficientes intellectuelles
aussi qu'ils ont pas beaucoup de
services en ce moment et leurs familles
le noël et white the wii puis les
services voulu oublier
vous l'avez fait à plusieurs reprises
ils sont limitées là et sont limités
puis dans certains cas il ya là pas du
tout puis compare déjà est exténué qui
entoure ces personnes là vous en savez
mais quelque chose aux essais c'est une
épreuve c'est une épreuve
bon ben on voit si de mettre un peu
d'espoir dans ce le vaccin est un
deuxième cette semaine
modern art on a on va écouter la
docteure en chef du canada qui dit que
d'ici la fin de 2021 dames en costumes
fin 2021
la plupart la majorité des canadiens
seront vaccinés on écoute actuellement
on a reçu comme ddd des données à des
des deux vaccins candidats prometteurs
de fois ai-je moderna et c'est tout va
bien avec comme lire l'approbation de
avec notre système réglementaire on
entend peut-être de recevoir les vaccins
a peut-être en janvier ou février
quand même josé
je lève mais j'ai mis pour vous cet
extrait là mon dieu mais j'ai écrit
là-dessus la semaine ne peut
qu'applaudir avec tout le monde je dire
on va en prendre un vaccin on va en
prendre quatre y en a non bien sûr etc
etc les deux revers de la médaille en a
qui reçoit 100 maintenant on peut lâcher
ça va mais dans les faits c'est cesser
la lumière au bout du tunnel désolé pour
les clichés mais c'est vrai et c'est ce
qui fait que justement il ne faut pas
relâcher c'est la raison numéro un parce
que il ya de l'espoir
bons élèves on a ceint de copies en
acide de commandes de vaccins je pense
qu'on a on a eu les chefs depuis une
dizaine de jours ça semble clair que et
moderne en effet ce jeune on est en
bonne place le pour recevoir des doses
oui parce qu'on avait réservé avec ces
deux entreprises et d'autres aussi des
doses suffisantes de vaccins et donc
tous combinés ensemble devrait permettre
de vacciner un très grand nombre de
canadiens
moi ce que je serais intéressé de
regarder c'est évidemment que c'est pas
maintenant qu'il faut relâcher les
mesures parce qu il y ait cette lumière
qu'on voit au bout du tunnel mais à quel
pourcentage de vaccination de la
population pourront nous relâcher les
mesures et ce serait intéressant
d'entendre plus plus longuement nos
autorités là dessus est-ce que ça soit
comme tout le secteur de la santé sera
vacciné quand toutes les personnes âgées
le seront 30% de la population
il faudra avoir un débat là-dessus aussi
quelques le risque plus risques
bénéfices qu'on sera prêt à prendre à ce
moment là ok un petit bond hélène je
recommence avec vous et michel c'est
josé suroît oui parce que monsieur août
où le chef conservateur qu'on va écouter
pas l'extrait trudeau l'extrait où tout
s'il vous plaît parfait sur la chaîne
convient huawei a qu'un décision
canadienne est ce qu'on va bannir les
produits hwa oui ou non on écoute la
chine menacent maintenant des citoyens
canadiens sur le territoire canadien
le premier devoir du gouvernement du
canada est de protéger ses citoyens
mais le gouvernement libéral est
tellement fasciné par la chine qui
refuse de protéger nos intérêts je
n'accepte pas
là
hélène on l'est on a l'impression que
qu'on accouche jamais d'une décision
quoi je parle de son panel de voir ce
que le canada va s'aligner aux états
unis à ce que le canada va interdire les
produits
c'est quoi oui est accusée d'espionnage
donc des pays à mieux se départir de sa
technologie là on en est au canada
on attend toujours ça fait des années
que l'on en parle
visiblement on reporte à toujours plus
tard parce qu'on craint que ça n'en peut
tous en fête et limin pour toujours les
chances de libération des 2 maicon qui
sont pris en chine alors j'imagine qu'on
ne veut pas prendre sa décision
maintenant mais le monde semble prendre
les décisions à notre place le fameux
réseau des frais bras et les cinq pays
qui sont alliés lors en matière de
renseignement donc autres le canada la
nouvelle zélande l'australie la
grande-bretagne et les etats-unis les
quatre autres pays ont déjà décidé de
bannir huawei et je me demande si à
quelque part le canada se dit pas que ça
se fera par attrition c'est à dire que
si tous les autres pays n'est ce soir
oui ça vaut comme se fait
automatiquement
j'ai noté kissy au canada les grands les
grands géants des télécommunications ont
tous signé des accords avec d'autres
compagnies que huawei pour le jeter les
bases de leur infrastructure ça veut pas
dire que huawei ne fera pas partie mais
y'a personne à dax signé de contrat avec
huawei alors peut-être que par la force
des choses cette incertitude féroce ce
que le gouvernement trudeau ne veut pas
faire officiellement c'est à dire mettre
à la marge
huawei et ça doit être clair pour vous
un michel et josua osih michel sait que
c'est que le g à trudeau ne veut pas se
permettre deux gifles et la chine
maintenant avec une décision comme ça ce
serait presque condamnés à mort dont
deux canadiens j'exagère mais à peine
ses deux otages c'est pas des est très
clairement le gouvernement je pense que
la théorie de dhelemme est assez bruyant
ça va se faire par attrition savoir tout
seul tous les autres membres des fraises
le forban rôle fropo plus mais on
donnera pas de directives faut pas
envenimer la situation des deux michael
marsh
the et c'est normal d'un autre côté
quatre dates à monsieur o'toole dire la
fascination du gouvernement pour la
chine fait que m bon ce type de bonne
guerre de politique partisane mais la
fascination commence à être pas mal
moins grande depuis un bout quand on
voit que le canada réagit sur la scène
internationale par exemple hier encore
qui demande une enquête sur ce qui
arrive aux ouïghours et qui parlent de
génocide
on n'est pas en train de faire gens ces
jours ci avec la chine et avec baden à
washington josée legault ça peut nous
aider aussi parce que ron une cohérence
dans le discours face aux chinois mais
ans
enfin enfin enfin et j'écoutais monsieur
au tour aujourd'hui le chef du parti
conservateur et je me suis posé la
question suivante s'il était premier
ministre du canada corp et il fait et je
ne suis pas sûr qu'il aurait fait ce
qu'ils demandent aujourd'hui à justin
trudeau de faire justement pour ne pas
m'être engagé encore plus la vie des 2
maicon qui sont des zonages et peut-être
dire porte de sortie signé par contre la
tuerie 15 secondes jeu hélène 15
secondes allez-y j'allais dire qu'il
faut pas oublier que les militants
conservateurs très à coeur la question
chinoise c'était une des choses qu'ils
aimaient auprès d'eux dans notre groupe
cette posture très sévère rigide entre
la chaîne et donc à ces gars là je pense
que monsieur o'toole fait ce qu'il fait
en ce moment parce que c'est que c'est
payant auprès d'un électorat
voilà mais là on est dans la politique
la réalité c'est que deux canadiens en
jaune depuis plus d'un an merci beaucoup
à vous trois bonnes soirées au revoir à
bientôt